are you going straight from here to a
merchant ship
are you are you auditioning for hipster
popeye what's going on oh you're talking
about this yeah i know
no see what i mean charlie brown and
popeye
together no it's like so we have that
cartoon on king of steam yeah
we have this merch lane theo walks in he
goes hey
they sent me these out you know they
they're [ __ ] stupid and toss them
like
that's dope he's like you like him like
i would rock the [ __ ] out of that he's
like
really i'm gonna go yeah it's from the
cartoon dude when we have the cartoon
yeah polly tune
and so i put on he's like oh it's
actually pretty dope so they're just
like one offs has
the the kingston label on that's cool
you were like what goes well with capris
yeah i'm like what could we wear this
one
now what technically just fashion wise
because you know i'm not
this is i mean it's not bad though what
are they what's happening what are these
these are jeans we can roll
like you can make them jeans here but
when i wear these i like to roll them up
into almost a capri thing yeah just when
it's hot out here it's very european
it's very euro yeah it's very boat
boatish here's the thing i feel like if
you weren't
a large man more people would say
something to you about you think
i think so i think i'd look cooler if i
wasn't so large really
yeah my style would look way better
fashion's harder for a big person yeah
how come it's dude you try finding a
size anything cool
that's also a lot of stripe on a big
part this is a yeah and it's in there
and they're horizontal big guys want
vertical yeah yes horizontal makes you
look bigger
so you think fashion is better on a
small person way better
look at nba players they look like
[ __ ]
and it's all custom-made too by the way
like going to gooch going to a high
fashion
place like off-white because urban's
gonna have bigger
like sizes but like you go to gucci
armani like dude i can't step foot an
arm on it can i tell you one look i am
not in favor of it all
you know the short short but kind of the
dressy the shorts but we're like the
dressy top
for girls no for the guys like when you
see lebron james and russell westbrook
i know that's not see i dig it i can't
do i dig it
the shorts with like the yeah the shorts
and the matching shorts it looks like a
like a onesie yeah yeah
what like the other day uh j.r smith i
forget what instagram posted maybe
kicks or something yeah this one here
yeah this is not my
but he but he you can't he he looks cool
he looks all right
he would look like [ __ ] for me i
don't know
i think it'd be better if you didn't
have the socks like that but dude
summer suit attire what
is your most regrettable fashion phase
for you and is there any fashion you're
doing now that you know i know i'm going
to hate this in 10 years probably the
scarf
i pry the scarf my kid in 10 years and
be like
why are you always wearing that gay
scarf all the time
like what was the pandemic he was like
when was the pandora 220
no this video is from 2024 dude okay i
know
i just rock with it now i get a new
tie-dye one coming it's gonna be so sick
is it yeah i'm gonna wear it in here
just for you dude
i really appreciate that thanks yeah
that would be really nice here
when i got off stage with the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figured out what you look like i'm
like what just run a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we gotta [ __ ]
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son